persuadé que des employeurs sur la
marché de l'emploi quand ils verront
deux jeunes avec un une licence non
perdait trop vide et une période de vide
va forcément préféré l'étudiant non père
est rude
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la crise
post- coded amène à des matières
premières qui coûte extrêmement cher
donc un coût de la ville qui a augmenté
énormément c'est très difficile et
on essaye de s'en sortir comme on peut
de réussir nos études
on
[Musique]
2 2
240 euros
240 euros a vraiment pour tout faire
c'est trouver des stratagèmes au
quotidien pour payer mans après c'est
vraiment se faire des courses en
sollicitant bien qu'est ce qu'il faut
regarder dans chaque rayon ce qui est
moins cher ce qui correspond mieux à nos
agents
[Musique]
le programme a été raccourcie donc
énormément de cours ont été mis à
distance des professeurs qui arrive pas
avec forcément l'informatique à des
moyens quoi des polycopiés balancer
comme ça d c'est ça aujourd'hui les
études et c'est vraiment un désavantage
et d'un combat